the gyro can experience your
split-second timing and counter shots
with Tony was that pretty spectacular
second to none no will beat me Conor
McGregor's gonna it's gonna be a [ __ ]
a race it's gonna be a you know we're
talking about milliseconds here and
that's the race that we'll have are you
looking forward to I would I do I want
to shut him up I love that I really
would do you think that's a possible
fight do the [ __ ] fighting right now
if I wanted to
you think so everyone is gonna say that
that I'm lying and if it was there I
would take it you know Daniel Cormier
said that the other day I'm not that
fighter for one day I have an
opportunity to do something that can be
unmatched in the history of our sport to
go in there to come off the
circumstances to be to be Tony like I
did go be Habib go be Conor that's
legendary so that's what you want to do
you want to beat khabib and then fight
Conor but you when you said you could
fight Conor right now why are you saying
that well he's calling me out but he is
he really cuz he was talking about -
well and I know that's not real he
doesn't want that I think he would take
the fight with nice man or you me okay
yeah he wants to fight Habib but I'm the
only way you have to go you had to go if
he could've got when he picked cowboy he
could have gone through me he could have
gone through me there's no you know if
you're a family someone think he matches
up way better with cowboy well that
doesn't matter that's irrelevant but I
think it is for him I think to make a
spectacular performance I think he felt
like he managed I think it was I think
it was smart yeah but now you're gonna
call for a towel shot know like the I'm
in a great position because for one I
get to fight for a towel there's five
hundred some-odd people on this roster
every single one of them would want to
be in my position right now but I also
have the ability to bring some kind of
I'm always drop like when it comes to
this word but a rhyme or a reason way a
way to a title shot for young guys that
come in they think politics run the show
they ultimately do but there is a small
chance that you get a say in your
destiny and eliminate politics and
that's what I just did
politics we're going to
I wasn't gonna get the fight Connor was
gonna somehow or someway get that fight
and now I got the chance to go out there
and I you know did what I did well just
through the virtue of your performances
you become incredibly popular then
that's enough that's enough its
popularity is everything this is a game
you have to win you have to win but it's
also the way you win like you and also
when and you winning the way you did in
Florida when there was nothing else
going on in the world
yeah there's no live sports and so you
winning the way you did and and doing it
in such spectacular fashion against a
hugely respected guy like Tony Ferguson
that makes you undeniable and when
you're undeniable weird things happen
you know timing is everything doors get
open timing is everything
it was a perfect time it was you know
destiny whatever it is you know I don't
put anything into any of those things I
just do what I can't do today but you
know timing is everything and it feels
like that was part of my destiny to have
the opportunity at that time under these
circumstances well it certainly is a
magical storyline if you were writing a
movie I mean that would be yeah but it's
the best way if I can when I go be
Habiba than I'd be Connor what what run
in the history of this board has been
better coming off two losses getting
counted out you know that's what I'm
here for
that I can inspire the world now do do
they have anything lined up for Connor
now because Connor keeps talking like
something's happening he's so back and
forth from the boxing to the MMA that
it's again it's all right he keeps
talking trying to talk I wouldn't've day
he's the number one yourself you're not
that where's this season like he talked
about doing the season and and don't get
me wrong I respect the [ __ ] out of him
he can fight his ass off but he was like
I'm gonna do a season um I have three
fights in three months or whatever you
said and the whole thing is is people
stop listening when you're not sticking
to your word and if you're gonna fight
fight stay irrelevant pick away class be
just consistent yeah as you are when you
fight because he's super consistent when
he fights like I say Talent yeah I said
in an interview that he was losing clout
among fighters and in the game Dana
White's laughing at him reporter asked
him he said Connor says he's fighting
Justin next Dean
laughs that's all the need right there
that's your losing respect so he has to
go and fight that kind of earn a
position I mean beating Cowboys nice but
he's got to kind of get another win
something else has got to happen to
really sell the public on 100% so you
can sell a certain percentage of public
based on his name and it was at 170 I
mean yes again there's the consistency I
look at it from a consistently sanz
standpoint it's like what weight class
you're gonna go in I feel if he was fine
at 145 he's very unstoppable I feel like
that's the way class for him but him
changing weight if I was a coach with
him I'd be like hey man pick away class
be consistent he's so great for 145 but
again if I ever made that one again but
again he he came from blowing super
hungry he's getting up the stronger
dudes
yeah his speed is key and when you go up
bigger weight classes you start to start
to lose your speed well that's what the
fight I thought was so ridiculous yeah I
saw them lose mine was posting photos of
that I'm like that is so crazy because
Oman is enormous and he's so powerful I
was sparring with him for this camp
William he's a big dude yeah he's a big
guy he's big he's strong as [ __ ] like
when Guzman gets ahold of guy who drags
him to the ground he's an incredible
wrestler in his mind to his minds very
very powerful so when I was looking at
dad I was like wow that's that really
happened totally you know but it's not
yeah that's tough I something happened
yeah I even texted Dane about that one
I'm like come on man
I don't know nothing about that that's
when when Connors talking about 70 like
after he fought cowboy he was like I
feel so good at 170 I'm like okay I'll
show ya I think he really did feel good
but 55 yeah exactly
exactly so your ultimate goal is to do
that to be Conor and then what do you do
do you have a long-term Poirier [ __ ] out
of here and that's it that's all I need
Wow what do I need after that yeah that
would be legendary I'd make plenty of
money which is ultimately what I'm here
to do and it took control of my destiny
which is all I asked for yeah so it's
good you might be you know business-wise
the smart move could be
you know right now to fight Connor
because obviously that's a lot of money
I think you have more leverage
but pleading to be I make way more money
a lot more money if when I beat him even
in fight you know if kind of Connors not
terrified Poirier he doesn't he's he's
not on my list
Connors not message habibi and Poirier
are the two on my list right now those
if I fight them too with big paydays and
I'm good
[Applause]